this is the news Windsor had been
waiting for a royal baby boy born safely
and now at home just a short walk from
where Harry and Megan got married there
was a year ago that we were standing
here outside Windsor Castle for that
very first glimpse of Harry and Megan as
a newly married couple and now just as
then you can see Windsor has been full
of international media as well as locals
and tourists celebrating this special
news some royal fans have been here for
weeks and came prepared for both
possibilities Windsor is good at royal
celebrations and creating innovative
tipples to wet the baby's head
we've got Windsor baby which is brought
out from Windsor and Eaton brewery and
then we have our own special gin so we
brought this out for Harry and Megan's
wedding and since it nooses broke that
it's a boy we have dyed it blue we love
the Royals we love everything all the
state visits and everything that happens
whenever the Queen comes out so for us
it's really a special especially
considering Harry and William went to
school just down the roads of course
there was congratulations from beyond
Windsor like this from the top of the BT
tower in central London unsurprisingly
this half American baby got a welcome
stateside to the former first lady
Michelle Obama tweeted Barack and I are
so thrilled for both of you and can't
wait to meet him and Megan's former
co-star in suits Patrick J Auden wrote
just heard that the world just got
heavier by 7 pounds and 3 ounces much
love to him and his incredible parents
and Bishop Michael Curry who electrified
the Royal Wedding last year with his
rousing address wrote congratulations to
the duke and duchess of sussex and
prayers are blessing for them and their
baby Abbey
who was already drawing crowds from
across the world I love Harry so much I
make an altar there are such a beautiful
people and I was thinking maybe it's
gonna happen today I'm just you know
very glad yeah
so the wait for the birth is now over
but the question here when will we know
a name and what will it be
Katharina vertices Sky News in Windsor